[Music]
in smuggling non-news Oh submitted by
what are you thinking about yeah I need
to know what's in here what are you all
in about yeah but then the underneath
her nun clothes I pictured this really
hot lady red lingerie yeah just like a
bunch of sheets yeah yeah as well shaven
I always don't think that when it comes
to nuns and boys like home maybe she's a
smuggler dressed up as a nun oh that's
good no I wanted to be hot and like her
face when you just said that I just I
saw old Mexican guy with a mustache
wearing nun clothes wasn't that part of
Sister Act where she taught all the
sisters how to wax really remember that
I think that's a porno
oh that's a porn on your right that's a
porno parody submitted by Stephanie
Ramos Ramos a nun was busted for
smuggling cocaine in her shoes was she a
real nun that's the point now a real nun
oh well she know that's a sin did she
know she was smuggling is it well that's
a bad shall not steal they're still
trying to figure it seems like she did
yeah good things like she really didn't
know what she was doing but then they're
still trying to figure it out if she
knew like to what extent does she know
damn was it for personal use how amazing
is that like nuns have such good
branding that she smuggling cocaine in
her shoes and they're like she probably
didn't know that's the mean though
unfortunately the church has such bad
like PR now because of all the freakin
scandals like even the new scandals
there's a bunch of new people there's a
whole new wave of new scales which I
predicted by the way on this show like
friggin six months ago or something I
was like just wait for the next frickin
Catholic Church wave of scandals right
exactly especially molestation like you
mutters yeah I think it all stems from
not being able to have sex cuz they're
all allowed to have sex and that's an
illogical human need and they tried to
police themselves and they try to kind
of go like oh let's just send father
father pedo
to a neck to another [ __ ] parish right
and then they just hope that you'll stop
doing it and then he just keeps
molesting more and more kids yeah marge
is the watchman
yep who is checking yeah it's a oh no
will police ourselves don't matter which
is none she's from Missouri she smuggled
two pounds of cocaine into Australia
she's a nun awesome big ass shoes I'm
checking nuns first now nuns clergymen
priests older that to wear civilian
clothes I mean maybe she's not like a
full-on nun and I could do that maybe
nuns have like it's like a casual
Fridays oh I think the nun reserves yeah
it's like the National Nanyang I'm
agreeing agreement do you think other do
you think more like Orthodox nuns or
whatever look at this nun and be like
she's not a real nun
how dare she take that nun bit like you
like because she's not interested yeah
like maybe there's like super nuns that
are like nah she's not a part of the
real nun or nunnery
you said super nuns and I pictured a nun
with the Cape I pictured her relying
pictured a nun living up to her vows
yeah well cocaine thou shalt not do
cocaine is not in the Bible mm-hmm
so she's like well I can't [ __ ] that's
clearly written so I'm gonna get my
throw some other way I'm down I mean
that's why I heard the [ __ ] altar boys
because they're like there's no such
thing as like um but sodomy is a sin in
the Bible
yeah but we make up their own rules
altar boys are a position at the church
just so they could be [ __ ] by
everybody the truth
it's unfortunate reality I'm the best I
wanted to be an altar boy so bad you did
yeah you did yeah didn't you grow up
like Buddhism no I went to private
school I was Catholic
no it was Christian but they had like
altar boys and then there's the guys
that call and light the candles yeah and
I was like [ __ ]
[ __ ] pick me and then after service
is over they got that thing that goes
and it's not yes nice all the candles
and then after that sir over they get to
go to the cocktail slow forward always I
got to play piano for one of the hymns
but only that's not the same as be an
altar boy though not the same I'm not
and you get to wear that angel thing
those [ __ ] robes yeah they look tight
with that [ __ ] red thing always be
real yeah yeah I want see your heels
whoa how'd she get caught this that's
really good that's really tight oh how
did they see that she should have gonna
[ __ ] this is substance I guess like
they have different colors for it oh so
just look so de helix so dense yeah
stupid she should have done TSE I was
about that you if you do TSA PreCheck
you'll have to [ __ ] take off your
shoes in Australia they don't have a TSA
PreCheck a nice family they don't they
don't got [ __ ] Kangaroo Express for
some Kangaroo Express check I like the
idea of a pablo escobar's type being
like get him on pre-check be fine yeah
yeah so her lawyers saying that she was
groomed to provide financial gain for
some guy that she met online
oh she never met in person but oh you're
right it goes back to not having to have
sex no they're so desperate yeah she
ended up texting him can you promise you
will never leave me you are my only and
first true family man the text
masturbation's us into I think spill
your seed oh yeah cause it's all about
your Celebi right yeah you gotta be
completely celebrating well I don't
really spill it do girls Spiller see the
dirty masturbation no it I don't think
they even know that they can masturbate
hmm cuz girls build their seed once a
month what about love thy neighbor
but that's punishment for eating the
Apple oh okay
you guys are made from our rib so you
better shut your mouth right now I like
that this is not for our review existing
excuse me is one drink of barbecue lover
what oh just one yeah yeah okay are we
cute she's really she's a real joy Bart
she's a real joy but some of my ribs
aren't that nice just one anyway yes
none here she flew from Missouri to
Texas and then to Trinidad and Tobago
and then she went to syrup how do you
pronounce that sternman surname in South
America no I don't know where she's
taking the coke the other way Suriname
why should taking it back to the source
random yeah in South America she's going
back and supposed to read love but she
might've got it which in South America
oh she's getting a refund and then she
went a refill did she take it to South
America cuz she could have picked it up
in South America and I went to Australia
yes then the last stop was Austria yeah
yeah that's probably what happened yeah
yeah from tebah go to South America and
she's on her way to Australia on the
brighter side though she's a jet setter
she's going places
so she got to travel yeah I want to go
to Texas and surnames
dude I got in trouble when we landed in
Australia because I had an orange from
here and like the dog sniffed me and
they're like you go to the side Siri
what the [ __ ] and then they're like oh
my god I didn't know I couldn't bring a
[ __ ] orange I'm sorry and then made
it a big deal there's seeds right yes
they're airport is way more stringent in
ours really looking like in general
oranges with [ __ ] like you could have
been more than an orange I could have
done that that sounds exciting no no
then you peel them you're they would do
on dizzy day for like the seniors
because you know you inject it with
alcohol yeah Wow so cuz you can't break
out them also they bring oranges or
fruits or whatever and mostly oranges
and you inject it with vodka damn you
got a crazy you get the [ __ ] syringe
to do that you can get a syringe from
Vienna medical medical sorry I will
watch this show it's it's kind of like
cops but it's custom
for the airport and it was it was based
out in like Australia and there was this
Asian dude bringing over like [ __ ]
fish and just straight-up bagged up dead
fish yeah no I sell her to smuggle I
don't know if it was just to eat or
whatever but he thought it was all good
and they're like sir you can't do this
like how did you even bring it through
and then you say it's for me I catch it
yeah dude every single time I wasn't
even on ice or anything no it was just
bagged up and wrapped up in newspapers
and was just in his backpack yeah it was
just in the bag editor like oh sure we
can you can't bring this in and the guy
was like why but if the carry-on size
every single time that me and Nicky
travel I always get pulled over when
they put me in this machine he just
wants to brag about it
oh they always pull me over every single
time so they can follow me yeah but
looks like something's in his pocket is
not anything in his pocket it's a body
part I'm telling you it's harassment his
dick actually it's his balls but
everyone thinks this is dick yeah it's
harassment dude so they have to pad your
dick to make always every single time
every time I travel I know I'm getting
my balls fall oh yeah he's wearing these
he's wearing these thin little sweats
he's taunting he's teasing all of them
I'm a I'm a big tease he's a big thing
in life he's got his thin Batman sweats
on let me to have small balls they go
there and when I come out they're like
come here miss I'm like my mess
did you see the scanner madam we did
this one JK news where a cop was kind of
making sure that this dude had no
weapons and you grab this dick and you
like what is this he was about penas yes
it was a jakey news article
we were watching oh yeah important as
well yeah yeah
what is this that's my penis oh and if
you let go we try to pull here by he had
a good grip on it he was like what is
this whoa you should get the gun makers
are like weaponry makers should make
like some weapons and I feel like dicks
then you could sneak them in you're
welcome bad guys yeah why does the
barrel of a gun need to be straight when
it could be all rubbery right explosive
she's an innovative thinker okay what's
going now I know how the Wright brothers
felt never get that plane to fly rip
oral Bakker
can you believe their name they're like
popcorn now you're gonna get so laughed
out when I shoot you with my dick gun a
dick gun you won't you won't hit me
you'll mess it'll be dangling all around
okay we'll see it's on you should invent
the dick gun I want to see it oh you
know how they have those that you do
like the click for those penis implants
and then it gets the dude hard oh thank
you she's on my team and I need someone
with vision who shares my vision
there's your right brother right there
yeah I just pictured a gun like this
like where this part is like a real gun
and then the handle is just that is just
the dildo pointing downwards the handles
trying to hide it in your seniors woke
up I mean like if you had it this way
and then people grab it there that's
that's the dick no the whole thing has
to be a dick yeah no yes so this is the
boss yeah and then it's flaccid so be
you [ __ ] it you got a [ __ ] it so it gets
a rag that's good
you better trademark that thank you
[Music]